you can't audition to get the job if you
do that you're going to
be depressed because how many jobs are
you going to get you have no control
over that you know but what you can do
and this is from me on the other side of
the table like watching auditions like
what you the auditions that land are I
can tell that you had a perspective
you made a choice you prepared and you
executed on that choice and whatever
those three things were you gave you
provided a tape that was your best
presentation of those things and then
ain't nothing else you can do about it
you know what I mean like we can debate
oh like we might say oh well she's you
know the person that we've already cast
for her sister she doesn't look anything
like her and it's a big stretch because
that's important and so like no we don't
hire that person they may have been the
best person